good morning everyone and uh welcome
here today as uh i welcome dr russon
here uh with myself
as we share uh an important update on
our next steps with respect to lifting
covet 19
restrictions here in manitoba
the past two years have been incredibly
challenging i think for all manitobans
we all have had to give up something
and some more than ever
some more than others
some have lost loved ones to this virus
others have had to isolate from family
friends and neighbors
businesses have had to adjust their
operations
close their doors
and lay off staff
students teachers
and parents have had to adapt
to a virtual way of learning
our children and youth
have missed out on sports
on music on other extracurricular
activities
we've had to mask up we've had to stay
apart from one another
and we've had to roll up our sleeves to
get those vaccines
we've had to forego birthday parties
weddings anniversaries
and even end of life celebrations
manitobans have put their lives on hold
and it's time that we give them their
lives back
i want to thank all manitobans
who have been patient and sacrificed
many things in their day-to-day lives
today we offer hope to those who have
been waiting for a long time
to see that light at the end of the
tunnel
the restrictions have placed many
burdens on manitobans
and now that we see the pressure of our
hospital system starting to ease
it's our responsibility of government
to ease those restrictions on manitobans
with key covet indicators improving we
are pleased to announce that we are
accelerating our plans to ease public
health restrictions
starting next week
effective tuesday february 15th
all of manitoba will move to
yellow or caution on the pandemic
response system
effective tuesday march 1st
the required use of vaccine cards
will be eliminated in manitoba
an effective march 15
mask requirements and all other
restrictions
will be eliminated
and for further details on these
and other details i will now pass it
over to dr russon well thank you premier
good morning everyone i'm brent rusin
manitoba's chief provincial public
health officer
and so based on our
data and our modeling we can see that
omicron has peaked and is beginning to
subside in manitoba
all the indicators that public health
considers
are moving in the right direction at
this point
and so just like many times in this
pandemic we've had to shift our response
based on what we're seeing with uh with
the virus
and as a result of what we're seeing now
with the
the trends and the modeling is we are in
a very important transitional phase for
a covid19 response here
and again we're going to shift our
approach and so this means that we can
move forward with relaxing some of our
public health restrictions
next week
tuesday february 15th
so at that time the entire province will
be moving to yellow or caution under the
pandemic response system
and one of the
largest
changes that people will notice is that
we'll be lifting
many of the occupancy limits from most
places
including gatherings at
private residences
so this will apply in spaces like
restaurants bars indoor outdoor sporting
events and casinos
capacity limits will also be removed for
outdoor public gatherings
but will be limited to
50 people indoors unless proof of
vaccine is is required
so proof of vaccination and mass
requirements are going to remain in
place
for the next number of weeks
however beginning on the 15th
those aged 12 to 17 will no longer have
to provide proof of vaccine or recent
testing to participate in indoor sports
and recreation
so we're providing more detailed
information today about other changes
that you'll be in place next week
and to guide
to your specific circumstances so like
the rest of the province schools will be
changing to yellow on the prs
masks will be required indoors for staff
and students but will not be required
during physical education classes
medical mass will be recommended but not
required
beginning next tuesday there also be
changes related to isolation
requirements
that start moving us from public health
rules
to public health recommendations and
more closely what we should be
adjusting to
in a typical respirator by our season
so
if you have symptoms or test positive
cova 19 you're going to continue to be
required to isolate
we want to
ensure give yourself time to feel well
and isolate for the minimum of the five
days
but close contacts will no longer be
required
to isolate
regardless of your vaccine status
if you live with someone who has
symptoms and test positive we're going
to recommend that you self-isolate
but it's no longer going to be required
under a public health order
for the next several weeks
proof of vaccination will continue to be
required
because this is a reasonable measure
that keeps us safe we know that it's
really the
tremendous vaccine uptake that we've
seen in manitoba that's gotten to us to
this place right now the ability to
loosen our restrictions
and so it's still
with or without proof of vaccine it's
always going to be our message to get
that vaccine that you're eligible for as
soon as you are eligible for it
so this is a incremental plan and we're
going to continue to move that path from
public health restrictions to public
health recommendations
and so for many of you it feels like
these restrictions have been in place
for so for too long and and for others
might be apprehensive about our gradual
reduction
in these restrictions
but we know that
from the very first public health order
that we have signed these were always
intended to be temporary we knew that
this pandemic would have would come to
an end we knew that the public health
restrictions
would come to an end and we are now on
that path moving forward
so we continue to have a lot of tools
at our disposal
we've talked about the fundamentals in
the past many times so we know we still
want people to stay home when they're
ill
we still want people to get vaccinated
to wash your hands to cover your cough
and sneeze
we know that
as we eventually move to public health
recommendations regarding mask use that
mask use is still available to
manitobans if you're indoor and indoors
and places where you cannot distance
we'd still recommend you consider
wearing a mask
just no longer going to be a requirement
at some point
we are
easing the restrictions on gathering
sizes but again
we suggest manitobans consider the size
of those gatherings that they'll have
based on
the risks of yourself and your guests if
you are at significant risk
for severe outcomes related to covet 19
if you're
an older age group if you're underlying
medical conditions you need to be very
cautious about the
number of contacts you have outside your
household
but again we're moving to those public
health recommendations
rather than restrictions
if you have symptoms of covet 19
even mild
and you're at
increased risk of severe outcomes get
tested as soon as possible we now have
treatments available we have monoclonal
antibodies which have been present for
uh for some time we have pax levitt the
oral treatment what we're finding now is
many people who would be eligible for
treatment
they are testing positive
and have underlying health conditions
they're testing too late they're
presenting longer than the five days
after symptom onset so our medication
isn't going to be useful so if you're an
increased risk of severe outcomes
get tested as soon as even the mildest
symptoms start because we do have
treatment options available now
so we are certainly
turning the corner in the pandemic
it wouldn't have been possible without
the tremendous work and tremendous
sacrifices of manitobans the
very high level of vaccine protection
and so at this point we are starting
that path to public health
advice rather than restrictions but
we're going to do so in an incremental
way and continue to follow those
indicators that we've been following so
long so so thanks again to all
manitobans and i'm going to pass it back
to the premiere
thanks dr rusin it's because of
manitobans collective efforts and your
dedication your compassion your
willingness
to protect one another that we are here
today and able to confidently move
forward
to lift public health restrictions
i said several weeks ago and you'll
recall that we must learn to live with
this virus
and part i think of living with this
virus is mitigating our own risks
and doing what's best for for our loved
ones
i'm vaccinated my family is fully
vaccinated and i will continue to
encourage as many manitobans to get
vaccinated as possible
but the choice to get vaccinated is
yours
as a government we have encouraged as
many manitobans to get vaccinated as
possible and we will continue with those
efforts
but it's time for a new normal to begin
in manitoba
we need to end the divisiveness between
families between communities we need to
move forward
it's time
to bring manitobans back together again
i think today is a good day for manitoba
and i'm confident that we will have
many more great days ahead of us
there is great hope for a positive
future in manitoba
and that hope and opportunity i think
starts today
thank you ready to take some questions
we talked about data and
i the last time here you said the data
shows we could release restrictions and
with respect neither of you
released any data we don't see the waste
water monitoring we don't see the
absenteeism reports you're talking about
you reference data again where is the
data that suggests this is the proper
course of action we'll release that data
when
as soon as we can yeah i think i'm going
to be out at the my usual
media availability next uh next
wednesday and i'll i'll present it there
sorry we're here now and you're
announcing this now this is the second
time you've said data supports this is
the second time you've said that both of
you without presenting data why not have
that now i even gave your folks a heads
up today saying we will i will be asking
this question yeah we will release that
data if we can do it we can probably do
it uh sooner than that
brent i don't see any any reason not to
drowsy did you recommend public health
recommend the removal of the mask
mandate the removal of the proof of
vaccination mandate
on these dates well we i mean certainly
we recommended the the removal of all
public health restrictions uh you know
the day we first
issued them we knew they're going to be
temporary so we're following um
you know the data and we'll release that
um and yeah and and we knew that all of
these measures are going to be temporary
um and so
we had
made some recommendations on what that
could look like various factors
and then looking at the data here we've
sort of uh we've expedited by kind of a
week compared to what we had before
these ones were originally going to
expire on the 22nd but from what we're
seeing we've uh we felt comfortable with
moving it to this date people you've
given the drain on the health care
system and the fact that we still have
icu that is well over our normal
capacity did you recommend these changes
on these dates we recommend well we we
work with the healthcare system where
we're in nc command so we meet daily
with that system looking at that that
very capacity looking at what our
modeling tells us in the direction of it
so
so yes we were we are uh recommending
that that incremental uh release of
these again cautiously right we're not
doing it overnight we're watching it and
at each step we're going to continue to
watch those indicators remembering that
the incubation period of omicron is much
shorter than uh than some of those other
strains so that two-week period
gives us a number of incubation periods
to watch madame premier how much of this
is political people are going to look at
this timeline that has been moved up and
say that you're giving in to the
pressures of the protesters that are
sitting outside the legislative building
right now not at all
um
what i would say is that this has been
ongoing i mean uh
dr russon said uh you know
i guess weeks ago that we were looking
at
probably the spring
wherein we would be removing all the
restrictions
and that was before protesters were out
in you know the front
of the legislature
so i mean we have been having these
discussions for some time we've been
following the data
the data is now telling us that
the icus are on decline the icu capacity
for covet patients is on decline
the hospitalization capacity is is on
decline
and
you know so now it's time to i think
safely move forward with the reduction
of these restrictions i think you know
today is about all manitobans
and all manitobans who are tired of
of this pandemic who want to move on who
want to get their lives back
you know this is a day for all
manitobans what do you say to the
protesters outside we're seeing doug
ford in ontario today issuing a state of
emergency we have our borders that are
blocked here at emerson we have people
that are not leaving outside that are
planning another protest outside banter
trails hospital on saturday
yeah what i would say i have reached out
to the prime minister and i've asked for
what is the plan and his plan moving
forward to deal with this it's nothing
that's unique to manitoba obviously
we're seeing it across the country there
needs to be some sort of a plan on the
parts of the federal government to
ensure that we can have the movements of
goods
across our border and that that's that
that's not curtailed in any way so i
have reached out to him i think this
needs i think he needs to reach out to
president biden as well and and look at
some sort of a collaborative approach to
this it's happening on both sides of the
border
and so certainly we've done that i have
reached out to uh to governor uh burgum
as well of north dakota i will be having
a conversation with him this afternoon
to see how we can work together when it
comes to the the protests that are just
outside the grounds of the legislature
it's obviously in the purview of the
winnipeg police and and
i have been in touch with the mayor and
we will have ongoing discussions on that
as well to ensure that we're taking a
collaborative approach to this
movement
dave asked to meet with you have you or
minister guertsen or mr friesen who are
representatives of the southern health
region where a lot of the protesters are
from have any of you reached out to meet
with any of the protest organizers so i
did receive a letter i believe it was on
tuesday
from the
the protesters outside the legislative
grounds
obviously we've been uh you know
occupied with with other things here
looking at modeling look at looking at
at the data to ensure that we can you
know safely put together a plan that to
safely reopen manitoba and so uh i think
you know that's what we have been doing
you know having said that i don't i i
i'm not saying that i would never meet
with them it's just that uh you know
there's there's a lot of demands on on
all of our times and i think what's
important is that and i want to thank
actually the winnipeg police service for
the incredible work that they're doing
uh working with the protesters to ensure
that things don't escalate to a point
um you know that that it's dangerous and
if if it does you know then we'll have
to take some action but and we'll
certainly work with uh with uh you know
the mayor and others out there of course
the winnipeg police falls under under uh
the city's purview but um you know we're
working collaboratively i think
we're seeing widening protests across
the country here in manitoba as well
some with a hard right element that is
let's face it you know or not here about
vaccine mandates
people in every corner of canada are
disappointed in every level of
government instead of taking action it's
pointing the fingers at the other saying
well you know it's their responsibility
you were just asked the question you put
the trudeau you pointed to bowman
what are you going to do as the leader
of this province to ensure
that our economy is safe
and that the goods of services flow what
are you going to do well i just i think
fit finished saying what i what i have
done
and you know i think this has to be a
collaborative approach to this i mean
you know this you know some of these
protests are taking part at the at the
border as a result of something
that the prime minister of our country
implemented it's not something that's
unique to manitoba but i haven't walked
away from that i mean i am working with
them i'm reaching out to the governor of
north dakota um you know i'm i'm working
with uh the mayor and we're gonna work
in a collaborative way through this
extremists are involved
with respect uh you know to what's
happening outside the legislative
grounds i think it's important to let
the professionals do their jobs that's
the winnipeg police and uh i think we
need to have respect for what they are
doing to ensure that
that it doesn't escalate and that's what
their job is and they're doing an
amazing
a hospital job going to be targeted on
saturday what are you guys doing to stop
that so uh basic you know listen the
people have
the right to
you know peaceful protests
uh in our country that's part of being a
democratic society
and you know and but there needs to be
balance and there shouldn't be you know
people
um protesting in front of schools and
hospitals and those those places and
and certainly you know we did reach out
i know the minister of education and i
um you know reached out uh yesterday to
ensure that you know this doesn't get to
a dangerous situation
and uh you know um we need to make sure
that we work with the professionals the
the officers who are trained to deal
with these situations so that they don't
escalate to levels where it's you know
it's beyond control and so i just want
to thank all those officers for the
incredible work they're doing to ensure
that we don't get to that that phase
we're going to jump to zoom now now go
to the zoom call with reporters who will
have one preliminary and one follow-up
question
up first this morning from the brandon
sun
kyle
uh good morning uh premier you started
off by talking about all the sacrifices
that manitobans have made throughout
this pandemic
um are you concerned at all that uh by
taking us out of these restrictions
perhaps prematurely that you'll be
subjecting us to more hardship in the
future if we have to
you know uh go back into uh
restrictions due to a new variant or if
the the pandemic takes a nasty turn
well thanks for the the question kyle
and and of course we're making these
decisions and developing these plans
based on
the data and the modeling that we've
seen and so we'll continue to move in
that direction
these restrictions were never put in
place to be there permanently and i
think manitobans have sacrificed a lot
in their lives
many many manitobans haven't been able
to see their their loved ones you know
children have been
um you know away from school at times
they've been away from their sporting
events you know these are not easy
decisions that have been made in the
past but they were necessary to to
protect manitobans
now it's an opportunity to move beyond
that
um and based on on what we're seeing i
think we're very confident that this
plan is uh is put in place uh you know
with incremental timelines it's a plan
for manitobans so that they can they can
plan for their future as well so i think
it's it's time for that
all right thank you and have uh
have you guys discussed the possibility
of instituting a state of emergency
similar to what doug ford over in
ontario announced this meeting
so i mean again i would go back the rcmp
is is monitoring the situation along
with the uh the the border patrol people
and
i think we need to let the professionals
do their jobs i know that they have been
in touch
with the protesters they have now
identified someone who is in charge of
the protest at the border and i think we
need to let the professionals do their
jobs
when it comes to this they are trained
to de-escalate situations and
and i know with uh in my previous time
in in as the minister of justice i
worked with those
law enforcement officers the rcmp the
winnipeg police service and and they do
incredible work to ensure the they
continue with the safety of of
of manitobans so we thank them for their
work
thank you
from cjob
clay
okay can you hear me now hi clay
all right
um
dr
we all know omicron is quite contagious
are you worried that
these restrictions
a number of the restrictions being
lifted
could cause
a lot of people to
let their guard
down yeah and so what we see right now
is that there's been a
a significant amount of transmission
that has already occurred due to omicron
and that wave has now peaked based on
you know the the amount of manitobans
that have been infected as well as our
very high vaccine rates
so so the modding that we're looking at
what we see has occurred in other
jurisdictions
this is the appropriate time now to
begin
easing some of our restrictions but of
course following those indicators that
we always do
that's why we're doing it in a stepwise
manner
but based on what we're seeing here and
in other jurisdictions this is that that
appropriate time to start
easing our restrictions
premier is it your
hope that
easing some of these restrictions are
going to end these protests
well i think
what this does is easing some of these
restrictions is giving manitobans
more freedom in their lives and i think
that they have sacrificed a lot in their
lives over the last couple of years and
i think
many manitobans have been waiting for
this for some time and and i think this
is about giving that that hope and
opportunity back to manitobans again
canada
alexia
hi um can you maybe um
i would like to know if the government's
a government intend to continue to have
this extra capacity for icu or
returned
pre-pandemic numbers of beds
so i believe um
minister gordon will be going out along
with dr david mateer this afternoon to
have
uh uh those are to
indicate what is happening with respect
to uh the icu capacity moving forward
with respect to surgeries and and
diagnostic procedures so
um i know that she'll have more to
minister gordon will have more to offer
and dr mateer this afternoon on on those
on those issues
thank you um and will you look at the
situation in alberta that's when after
they ease their own restriction to maybe
adjust hours based on their results
so i every province makes their own
decisions based on the data that they
have and i'll ask dr russon to to to
jump in here if you'd like as well but
you know we make our our decisions based
on the data and the modeling that we see
here in manitoba uh sometimes we look to
other provinces to see if there's trends
that we can learn from here and if there
are trends we can learn from we can act
on those
so those are always
opportunities for us as we move forward
from ctv winnipeg
michelle
hi i just would like for you to tell us
what are the benefits as well as
drawbacks
to accelerating lifting restrictions
like this
so i think um when it comes to the
acceleration of these restrictions you
know we make make that decision as dr
russon said earlier based on the the
modeling and the data that uh that we
see
and what we have seen is a you know a
fairly significant decrease in in icu uh
covid related icu and as well as
hospitalization covet related
hospitalizations
and so we believe that because
manitobans have really sacrificed a lot
in their lives that as the
hospitalizations start to ease that we
need to ease some restrictions uh for
manitobans as well so that they can get
back to
living
their lives and some some semblance of
normalcy
okay so
what thresholds are going to be used
potentially if we need to bring these
restrictions back because people aren't
going to want them once they're gone
so we continue to to look at at the
modeling and we're making these
decisions based on on the modeling that
we see
i think that and i and you know i'd
asked maybe dr russon to to jump in here
and and and make his comments on this
but you know we we make our decisions
based on the information that we that we
have in the time and we're very
confident i think moving forward with
with this plan that uh you know omicron
is different from delta from other
variants and and i think what we're
seeing is that uh we're in a situation
where we're confident that uh we can uh
move forward with this sort of cautious
and measured approach to easing of of
the restrictions some provinces have
chosen to go much more quickly um we
have taken what i think is as a cautious
and and measured approach and so
that's what we see before us today
yeah and so certainly we've done this
before we've we've loosened restrictions
uh restrictions have never been
what we've uh interpreted to be
permanent
and so and then at times we've had to
reinstate them so i don't think anyone
really wants restrictions in place but
when when they were required in the past
we've we've loosened them when
appropriate and added them back on if if
necessary what we've seen now is that we
have such a tremendously high
vaccine uptake
the the thought is that we're at a point
where we can
look to
to remove these restrictions outright
and hope never had to have to put them
in again
but that's going to depend on what we
see with the virus
with the virus further variants are not
certainly not out of the question and
we'll have to deal with that as that
arises but we're not going to leave
restrictions in unnecessarily
just because there may be a time where
we we face this virus again
from city news
mike
hi premier i know you were asked this
already but the timeline of pulling this
press conference together it does seem
coincidental two days ago the new
restrictions kicked in
um
the city just met to discuss these
protests
are you telling manitobans who are going
to be questioning this it's purely
coincidental
that the timeline was accelerated as the
protests continue look as a government
we don't make decisions based that are
this important to manitobans based on uh
protests that are taking place this was
not a decision that was made
because of what's going on and protests
that are taking place in the province
this is a decision that is made for
manitobans who have sacrificed much of
their lives for the last two years and
are ready for this manitobans are ready
to get their lives back and that's what
today is all about
uh thank you and my follow-up question
is you commended police for their work
on this protest
manitobans of the downtown area probably
would uh think differently they have
there have been reports of verbal
assaults
horns going off at all times of the
night people losing sleep people who
work night shifts losing sleep during
the day
um can you just tell me exactly what
you're commending police for and if you
think this protest should have been
handled any differently so i i commend
the police for the work the the ongoing
work that they do to ensure that things
don't
get out of hand and escalate to a point
where you know it's it's dangerous for
individuals and uh but you know
we need to have a balanced you know
respect for one another here there needs
to be respect for the rights of those
individuals to protest in a
you know as long as it's in a you know
law-abiding way and we we ask for them
to also
you know respect those people who are
living in the vicinity
and and maybe think about about those
people as well and and and you know
ensure that you you know those people
have the right to you know live
peacefully in their homes as well and
not be disturbed in in the middle of the
night and i think those are discussions
that are taking place as a result of
discussions between the winnipeg police
and
those who are organizing the protest i
think you know there there was sort of
an organized approach to that that did
happen as a result of
those discussions with the professionals
with the police officers who are trained
in in this and so
um you know there's uh there needs to be
respect on on both sides of this for for
the rights of those individuals
from cbc national news
cameron
hi premier on that point um
we've been hearing from people
around these protests whether it's the
protests downtown
the
truckers at the border that can't get
across the border
or people that have been held up by the
the slow rolling
that their rights have been infringed
and they've been infringed now for a
long time
if you don't have the legal authority
here
you have mortal authority
are you willing to use your moral
authority to call for an end to the
protests
so again i mean i have reached out to
the prime minister um it is his purview
under his purview the the border um and
so uh you know i've asked what is the
plan to to deal with this we know that
it's nothing that's unique just to
manitoba
but it is happening across the country
of course we respect the rcmp officers
who are
managing the situation at the border
they are the professionals here who are
ensuring that i believe livestock is
able to get through that that there are
some truckers that are able to get
through but again it goes to both sides
there needs to be a balance
a respect for those uh you know who have
the right to peaceful pro protest
but also those truckers who have the
right to deliver those services as part
of their job
and so you know i have reached out also
to the governor of north dakota i will
be having a discussion with him this
afternoon just to see what's happening
on on their side of the border as well
of course those uh you know restrictions
at the border were put in place as a
result of um president biden
putting those in place and so i look
forward to having those discussions so
we are and i am acting on this
people have been honking their horns at
all hours outside of your office
people that live around it are sick of
it
is it not time to tell them to go home
follow the lead of other politicians in
this country
including doug ford and now the interim
conservative leader
has the point not been made premium
i think they have made their points
there's no question i think their point
is loud and clear but again um we need
to let the professionals do their jobs
to ensure that things don't escalate to
a point where they get out of hand and
so i take the advice of of those
professionals being the police officers
who are there at the front lines who are
gauging what the uh the temperature of
the situation is uh on a minute by
minute and hour-by-hour basis and and
making decisions you know that are in
the best interest of manitobans i mean
but you know i will ask those protesters
out there to please consider
you know the the livelihoods and the
rights of those individuals who are
living and working in in in downtown
winnipeg in close proximity
uh to their protests think about those
individuals and and what it means to
them because they have rights here too
from the verdant empire advance
and
hello
hi can you hear me hi ann
hi yes it's great to be honest paul
thank you
um
i guess i have watched from a distance
of course this protest
watch some pbc footage and go global and
ctv
as well citizen footage
some various smaller media as well
fighting
uh premier that this protest has grown
through drama
what has brought it to this
level
and how effective do you think it would
be for our uh our federal leader justin
trudeau to come and speak to them
or for you yourself um at our
legislature to come out and address
these people and
do some mediation that way
yeah i think you know again i think
people have the the right to to peaceful
protests as long as that's what is uh
happening and continues to happen i
think in other jurisdictions that is
maybe not happening right now and and
again those professional those those
professionals uh the officers who are
working you know right there the front
lines are our best to gauge the
situation that's happening you know
right there and right then and uh and
they will monitor those um and and we
continue and we're in close contact i
know the minister of justice i was out
yesterday answering some of these
questions i know he's working diligently
his department and working with law
enforcement to to gauge you know where
that's at and
i think we'll just continue to to
monitor uh the situation
i thank you
it's good to hear from you
i'm wondering do you have confidence in
manitobans
to now take health seriously and to
manage
uh throughout a flu season or a pandemic
of this level
uh i mean people are not rocking dead
all around us and we got that where we
thought to just
you know stay home and respect behave
ourselves and go forward
as the mandate
uh thanks anne listen i have every
confidence in manitobans to um to manage
their their own health and to to gauge
what they believe is best for themselves
and their families
and uh you know and that's why i think
the vast vast majority of manitobans
went out and got vaccinated we had a
very successful vaccination campaign
here in manitoba
and uh i think that you know again i
think manitobans are are getting a
little bit tired of of the restrictions
i believe that they want to move on i
think they want to get their their lives
back or some semblance of normalcy back
into their lives and of course that's
what we're here to do and announce today
and to give them
that their lives back
we now return to the news conference
theater the virus is still in the
province you're lifting uh mass mandates
not in personal care homes as well in
march what are you going to be doing to
keep vulnerable people like those in
care homes still safe given that covet
is still up there
yeah well for the uh for the higher risk
settings like uh personal care homes
like healthcare uh settings we're gonna
be you know working with the infection
prevention control experts there so
just like at other times in the in the
pandemic there may be added um
requirements in those settings so masks
may still be required in healthcare
settings and personal care homes for
instance um so so there's still more to
come on that will vaccination and
testing still be required in those
settings
for the people who work there so again
we're uh we're not going to do anything
unilaterally
we're going to work with those settings
but the idea right as moving forward is
that we are moving away from vaccine
mandates
and so that is the the um
the path we're taking when that exactly
will affect those areas we haven't come
to that yet
are you comfortable with these changes
that you've announced today given the
fact that the health care system really
hasn't had a chance to to have a breath
i know new admissions are dropping but
there's still people in those beds
icu capacity is still well over the
pre-pandemic normal
why why are these restrictions being
eliminated
in the coming weeks when the healthcare
system is still
not catching its breath yeah so i mean
there certainly is that strained
healthcare system it's it's come come
down from what we've seen in other
settings but again
when we if we frame things like that
where we're eliminating what we know are
tremendous negative impacts of the
restrictions as well so we always have
to find that balance right so we've
probably all know people who have been
adversely affected by these restrictions
so we can't just focus on one aspect of
the pandemic we know the restrictions
cause harm
we know that the health care system has
been strained we're looking for that for
that balance but we have to consider
the the adverse effects of these these
restrictions and do whatever we can to
have the least restrictive measures in
place
when i asked about extremism i wasn't
talking about this protest out here
let's process out here
cooperated with the police and has
largely been in one place but we are
seeing widening
protests at the border in stymac in
other provinces i'm going to ask you
again how concerned are you about
a far right hard right element doing
things to
undermine democracy in general in this
country well bartley i mean what i would
say is that every um protest is
different and if something starts to
escalate to a point where people are
doing things unlawfully then we need to
step in absolutely and we will monitor
that as it goes forward but i'm not
going to give a sweeping statement about
something that isn't reality that could
potentially happen in the future
what we're seeing here is and you just
said yourself what we are seeing is that
the police are doing they're doing a
very good job out here
i was talking about the ones we're
seeing at the border in this province at
the border in other provinces
surrounding and harassing children in
schools
and the encampment away from the main
one in ottawa down there we are seeing
extremists at work here whose goal
appears to be something far beyond
vaccine mandates and pandemic
restrictions i'm just curious why you
don't seem to be willing to acknowledge
that i don't condone any illegal
activity anywhere
so you'll be cool if uh climate change
or indigenous protesters block the
border in the future you'd have the same
approach
i think if things get violent and people
are and they're not being handled uh
appropriately you know and again i would
rely on the professionals within those
those individual protests to see you
know what the situation is there they
are the ones that know how to
appropriately de-escalate situations to
ensure that people can protest in a
peaceful way and so i i've said that
time and time again and
and i i think i've answered that
question what is the lifting so what
does the lifting of restrictions mean
for those who had to either get
vaccinated or get tested for work like
some healthcare workers is that going to
be removed now as well sorry
the people who had to either follow a
vaccine mandate or get tested to work
such as some healthcare professionals is
that going to be lifted as well will
people be able to go back if they are
not vaccinated without having to be
tested yeah those those details will be
ironed out through the course of the
next little while but eventually and and
what i've said weeks ago
is that you know and and other
professionals or other you know uh
doctors and and other politicians across
the country have also said that we need
to learn to live with this and so what
does that look like moving forward we'll
gauge those uh those circumstances but
eventually we'll have to uh to learn to
to live this
live with this where we're not imposing
you know unnecessary restrictions
because of one virus that's in the
community there's all sorts of
other illnesses that we need to ensure
that we're ready for that we're um that
our hospitals are ready for and and so
we'll continue to gauge that as we move
forward but that's not part of these
sorry i just want to be clear it's not
part of these timelines yet so as of
march 15 healthcare professionals will
still either have to be vaccinated or
get tested to go to work no i believe
that will be lifted but we'll uh
yeah we'll have those
didn't you answer that question
about vax requirements for people
working with the vulnerable sector and
you said we're going to look at that
we're yeah
certainly the
um
[Music]
the path we're on is to lift vaccine
mandates so this is uh speaking about
the ones in the uh
in the
public sector where we are
if we're looking at the in those tests
or or vaccine requirements again we're
probably looking at similar timelines on
that but it's just not
settled on on right
now and why not create why not create a
state of emergency why not brittany
asked you didn't quite answer that one
forgive me
because uh
again we are continuing to uh to monitor
the situation uh as it as it uh comes
about uh at the border and and at uh at
the legislature
and uh you know we if we have to take
action we will but for right now the
rcmp are doing their jobs uh very well
to ensure that things don't escalate
beyond where they need to be
thanks everyone
are you concerned about holding onto 4
we have three potentially three
candidates there that we'll find out
tomorrow
you